[Music]
three
two one action welcome back to off the
record where we talk about whatever
we want whatever we want there we go and
today we got oscar miranda with us yes
sir
thank you for joining us appreciate you
all
spanish connection mexican connection
she said your hair's messed up
it was wearing a hat yesterday and i
didn't wash my hair
for this morning so i did it but then
you know how yeah maybe it's not messed
up
oh we almost got a chinese mexican day
what is that chinese mexican chinese
mexican are you mexican no
okay damn i [ __ ] up and you're not
chinese i'm not chinese
okay so both of okay i i i messed up
it's uh it's an asian latin day i'm
salvadorian
asian because when you said that i was
like okay you guys are the
viva la chicano oh no you're good it's
still rasa that's all good
that's like me familias is that the rasa
what was that what is rasa it's like
people please oh yeah yeah
the actual meaning is race but it's like
yeah do you consider yourself
chicano yeah not really i mean i grew up
i i grew up around nothing but mexicans
so okay so it's like that's like me i'm
japanese by group mexican i can't see
nothing
but yeah like all my friends went over
mexicans yeah
so we have a mutual friend josh josh
leyva yeah one of the sexiest people in
the world yeah yeah no he's white
for sure how do you how do you know him
he's considered whitewashed
we have those um in uh asians too we
call them bananas
banana butter i don't even know how you
said that
twinkies or bananas i like twinkies oh
yeah that's the one i've heard
wait is that american or is that
japanese they don't have twinkies in
japan
oh yeah oh okay
i get it that's that's that's good i
don't know what they call them in japan
twinkies know if they want to be white
because you know have you heard what a
weeb is a weeb weeb
yeah they're like people that want to be
asian
like you could be white black or
whatever but there's hella into like
anime and all that [ __ ]
so what is the opposite of a weeb what
is
an asian person in asia that wants to be
white or something else my mom would say
that's being correct
because ever since i was a kid my mom
like see white people
that's right you gotta do that be more
white where does that come from
uh not that my parents explicitly say
that but like there's like this
understanding that the white way is the
right way you know and
and i feel like do do other ethnicities
feel this too within america
my my i've heard uh like when you speak
a certain way like my cousin for
whatever for example he's like he's a
gangster right yeah so like i was like
talking to my friend and i was speaking
like
proper he's like i can talk white too
bro
white too and i'm like what do you mean
he's like i can talk me speak properly
i've heard that like yeah just that's
what i feel like my mama watched like
gap commercials on tv i'm like you see
that took your shirt and the white
people are the right way and i'm like
what the [ __ ] i'm like i don't know it's
so weird
i guess it kind of like i guess i
understand what she means
because it's kind of like we're in this
country we should assimilate to
a white country probably
i just saw a video that uh was talking
about how like
white people took over everything like
how they over
over years and years they've made like
everything you glorify white
like jesus santa claus easter bunny
two fans oh yeah yeah i didn't even
think about them the last samurai
[Music]
yeah they're all white and i'm like i
never thought of that like everything
like yeah that's crazy that is crazy
complex yeah yeah it's crazy even within
the ethnicities there's like um
like colorism i guess where it's like
the light of your skin it's like within
that community like
you're good yeah that's true yeah cause
when i was little
i was way more like darker i guess and i
had this one
in particular she's like super colorist
because every time
she would always be like oh mika you
would be so much cuter if you were just
lighter
oh [ __ ] oh you're you're so ugly because
you're so dark-skinned i'm like
did you see that in any endearing way
like you're so fail
did you hear it really that is like that
but it's just the tone is
because it's very prevalent like how you
look too like weight is also very
prevalent like they'll tell you like wow
you're losing weight like that's the
first thing like wow
but is that a good thing or is that a
bad thing yeah because you know like so
in amer
in america right like you can't just be
going up to someone
and customs are different and insane and
just calling out their characteristics
oh yeah but a lot of asian culture is
like
a mom or auntie okay hey fat ass why's
so fat yeah
yeah it's not like it's not that harsh
yeah oh i don't i don't remember being
that hard
some family members because like my that
same aunt she would come to my mom and
like after my parents to work because
she's on my dad's side
so then after like my parents divorced
and my mom would see this on again she'd
be like
oh marielena look it looks like you've
gained weight
and i'm like that sounds mean that's so
bad that's meaner than hey fat ass
yeah then she's like oh the diet's just
not working huh
and my mom's sitting there like that
sounds like the [ __ ] in a tv
show like that's a [ __ ] that's a tv
show
like oh you couldn't wait yeah you
always want to kill off that character
yeah yeah that's the character everybody
hates
yeah would you call it a backhanded
compliment or like yeah
it's like oh you sold your car your
finances aren't doing that good huh
yeah they're like damn what the [ __ ]
maybe you can catch up now
legit like that i'm like damn thea
that's crazy
that's why i abandoned family
yeah yeah all they do is just give you
backhanded compliments
all day i wish you could pick and choose
family the way you could pick and choose
friends
you can't just don't talk to them you've
done it
but for everybody else because it would
make your life so much better
but also i think the part that kind of
makes it hard
is with family there's this like
underlying obligation
you're like i [ __ ] hate this
[ __ ] but [ __ ] i'm related to
this
i know that's the part that i hate and
then i'm like why am i obligated to you
but i have to damn i don't think i don't
think i have anybody like that in my
family no
everyone you like or everyone that you
could just cut them out like nothing
anybody i could just cut out or that i
don't like
yeah yeah how big is your family they're
not that big oh yeah yeah they're not
that big
we're not like what's big to you true
uh shoot bro the sm the youngest for
a long time was my kid so there's like
no kids or anything yeah they're kids
yeah every six years two kids six yeah
boy you can't cut out your kid if he
gets enough
thinking about it though nothing you
know we do consider it sometimes
especially around that age yeah that's
why i was
telling you i was telling bart earlier i
was like i taught him how to do
everything like
on his own so he doesn't bug me anymore
you know um
so yeah that's that's pretty close to
cutting off right it's like dude just
just do your own do your thing legit
where we're at because we have a 12 year
old and that's exactly where we're at
right now where it's like
he's asking for something and i'm like
well if you do it like this you could do
it on your own
and so now he'll ask us again i'm like
remember we taught you
like we yesterday he wanted to walk to
7-eleven
and i was like like by himself yeah no
he wanted to go
but i didn't want to go and he was like
i mean i had to go because
you know so i'm just like hey take this
[ __ ] ring camera with you yeah i wish
dude
the whole time just give him a phone and
you just watch him live streaming
and you can watch him get kidnapped yeah
that's scary
dude i swear to god you guys aren't
allowed to get pregnant bro i swear to
god i swear to god i was thinking i was
like
i need to show you how to walk the
streets alone because this like i was
like getting out of hand
yeah bro i'm like this is too much
you're asking for too much
dude i mean we kind of did that too for
isaac to walk
to school alone because he just had been
wanting to walk to school alone
you guys did you guys track him we did
yeah in the car
we cracked right right next to him yeah
the first week
so he knew you guys are trying he knew
also because he even though he wanted to
be independent and wanted to walk to
school he was still
obviously like a little bit nervous and
scared so just did he do the whole movie
thing where he's off
yeah looking back at you guys
yeah there's always that awkward like
you know when you walk and you're like
really something like this side eye you
could see the side of it yeah and he's
all like stiff and stuff that was
definitely yeah he's honest
pretending he's taking a selfie just
looking at you guys
yeah hyper aware he's being watched and
then like all of a sudden he starts
walking
he gets closer to his friends he's like
not
we had like friends over it's like it
changes the way he talks and everything
he does pops he'll ask us something
he'll be like hey hey mom
uh you man you know can i can we all
play this game or watch this movie and
then
and then we'd say yes and he's like okay
cool and then you go to over swings like
hey yeah bro hey we want to watch this
boys
hell yeah see that like that shift
immediately and it's just the cutest
thing because you're like oh i remember
being that easy it's crazy bro because
like talking to girls and [ __ ] you're
like
hey what's up girl what's up they're
yeah you know just talking my mom's
gonna tell me what we're gonna have for
dinner the [ __ ] be buggered again and
[ __ ]
oh my god it's crazy because like i
don't even realize how
quickly my kid's growing bro like the
other day i seen him
he got i got him a tick tock a tick tock
a tick tock account
because he would like to just go he's
about to be gone too yeah and he like
yeah i know [ __ ] and he and he
eventually started wanting to make
videos
so he would post them and then he
it's crazy bro like i had no idea he
knew how to respond to people
what yeah so he would post his videos
and like i checked his account once that
one
one video had like over 100 thousand
views oh my god yeah i'm like
bro you're a little me right now like
it's crazy like but you better promote
your dad
yeah cause i'm i'm i'm done dude like
i've peaked it's your turn you know what
i mean and
um yes like some kid commented uh oh
cool vid and he wrote thanks bruh
and i'm like bro yeah he said bruh and
i'm like what
six years old six years old bro like
i make you nervous kind of yeah
personally
like because isaac has a tick tock too
but i was like you're putting the [ __ ]
on private
right like you're not gonna have
strangers follow you
yeah that's how i feel like he it's
crazy because there's a whole bunch of
other little kids in his comments
they're like wow they say [ __ ] like
night oh
cool video or or you know like they what
they these little things that kids say
in comments like
is there a let's go in there let's go i
think there's like one yeah
i saw one before isaac loves that uh
yeah
really ready to have no kids but i'm
ready to practice having lots of kids
i'm i'm still down to practice a lot
of practice um because our our sponsor
for today adam and eve
hell yeah they're hooking us up with a
lot of ways to practice
having children maybe you're not ready
to have a lot of kids
like me or even if you do you just don't
want more kids but you just want the
feeling
of the process of making kids right
and maybe you don't have a partner right
now right right now you could take
advantage of the down time and choose
almost any one item
at 50 off baby we went on the website
and there's all kinds of crazy [ __ ] so
if you're looking for ways to spice up
the sex with you and your partner yup
or even by yourself i'm looking at it
right now the whole masturbator section
for dudes
all kinds of pocket [ __ ] pocket
buttholes pocket all kinds of [ __ ]
dude they got ass like literally
some i am i'm probably i'm gonna get a
pocket [ __ ] wedge it in between a couch
and [ __ ] it
that's what i'm gonna do you're your
first love blow job
yeah i can't like the couch is always a
good
good thing to keep going back to you
know i'm not really gonna sit on nothing
there's a mouth there's a vagina
there's a [ __ ] mouth that's that's a
mouth yeah it's like this
it's a [ __ ] mouth there's a lot of
i hope not no that's it's better than
that but there's stuff for garfield
perfect yeah so you get all uh you'll
also get
10 free boredom busting gifts including
six spicy movies
a three-piece bonus kit and best of all
free shipping delivered discreetly right
to your door
so just remember to use the code otr
that's otr at checkout and you get 50
off so whether you're looking for sex
toys for yourself or with your partner
go check it out adamandeve.com use the
offer code otr get one item at 50
off yup that's otr go to adamandeve.com
and use offer otr
and get that 50 off baby nice yup what
are you gonna get
a mouth one probably gonna get a bunch
but
also i don't know i feel like these days
my level of exploration has gone really
really chill
i'm having more fun riding a bicycle
then
i got so nervous writing uh
fill in the blank oh you thought it was
i was writing a that that thing
that thing that girls all right right
now it's called the symbian or some [ __ ]
like that
i forgot it looks like a like a sabian
thing
yeah like a saddle yeah or something
right they've been writing it
yeah that's yeah i know yeah man i'm
kind of jealous that girls have way more
things they could [ __ ] around with
yeah we get to have more it's like sexy
and it's acceptable right so you have
like a saddle thing
with the thing right here and the girls
can ride it if you caught a dude writing
something with this dick in it and it's
all vibrating and [ __ ] and this feels
like it's kind of pathetic it's like
it's pathetic yeah it's a loser
yeah why is that yeah i don't know it's
not because you guys guys know that
[ __ ] a woman is always gonna be
better
than like a bag or a machine once the
machine gets better though girls better
watch the [ __ ] out
because we're gonna start [ __ ]
romancing robots
and cuffs i mean i think we've been
ready if the guys are ready to go i
think we i think we got it that's true
you guys have yeah
we're set we're good but what about when
you need that weight on your chest
they have those dolls blankets yeah and
all right rice
it's a dead [ __ ] sack of rice see we
got it covered y'all you go to the asian
market that's just huge as [ __ ] too that
shit's like
you can [ __ ] build a whole fort with
that on a budget yeah
it's good for good for the lockdown oh
yeah it's good for the lockdown man
i forgot that we're in a lockdown me too
yeah what's the highways like
like they're like populated with cars
again now how have you been holding up
during this whole pandemic
i've been chilling to be honest like i
think this is probably
the second or third time i've like shot
anything with people
just because everybody's so [ __ ]
paranoid about it yeah like yo you want
to shoot ah [ __ ] dog it's
nah like it's it can't do it you know
and i'm like bro like come on
come on bro you know you're not you're
not nervous about like
catching anything or whatever you're not
nervous now it makes me nervous yeah
i'll be home in the same room yeah i'm
not nervous
true at all i mean i don't go out i have
nowhere to go you know
you eased it i'm telling you this is the
first time i
have gone somewhere that's not a family
member he's been he's been quarantined
yeah yeah because there's nothing to do
you know what i mean everything
i realized i'm lying we just went to the
beach this past weekend but even then
we went to the beach tonight even then
everybody was so sick yeah right yeah
you know i'm like this is
this i guess did you go to uh zuma
that's a zuma
in malibu uh yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay yeah and that's the clean beach too
i jumped in santa monica water oh
i never heard malibu called the boo i
like it
yeah i i made it up yeah he did he did
oh okay
it should be i like it it's the boo it
is the booth let's roll with it
i didn't know it was a locals thing can
we can we go to the
i never met a central californian
character called oscar for malibu bro
oscar from the boo yeah where'd you grow
up did you grow up around here
i grew up in van nuys oh so you're you
are
kind of closer i grew up in the hood uh
yeah
yeah i grew up in the hood baby which
what is that
i don't know i just throw [ __ ] up bro
like
you'll throw it up here though i grew up
around get like gang bangers and [ __ ]
bro and like
they would throw [ __ ] up walking down
the street home yeah so like
kicking it with them i wouldn't throw
anything i just go like that to their
enemies or whatever i should be like
like this i would back like
how do we do this am i doing this right
bro yeah is that dangerous to do that oh
absolutely
yeah yeah absolutely but yeah i just
didn't care i keep my hands down
i was trying to be cool oh cool is what
it was yeah well and you have protection
but you're going like this how cool do
you look
but look from across the street you
can't really tell what i'm doing
you know what i mean so to them it might
look like i'm doing some crazy [ __ ] and
i can imagine they have some like super
vision that they're about wait that
doesn't mean [ __ ] bro
what are you throwing up dog pardon me
can you do it again
wait wait i didn't have my reading
glasses on me [ __ ]
it's cursive gangster dog that's cursive
gangster
yeah no yeah a group of men i gotta get
my homie binoculars on hold on bro
all right [ __ ] you fool all right yeah
he's the [ __ ] though
yo van nuys is like gentrifying isn't it
yeah bro crazy
yeah yeah a lot of apartments are going
up like it's
it's about that time though bro like
i've told my girl multiple times van
nuys boulevard especially like um
let's say victory to like oxnard
like all that [ __ ] is just so run down
it looks old i'm like it's about that
time bro like
you